For the first time ever,
we’re bringing together
an international all-star cast
of ex-Islanders
ready for some healthy competition
and a second chance at love.
It’s Love Island Games!
Things are going to be very different
this time around.
I feel the tension.
The challenges will determine everything...
I’m ready to win this thing.
...and ultimately which couple gets $100,000!
Winners win
and I’m a winner.
I’m here for love.
I’m ready to find someone.
Let’s go!
These games have the claws coming out.
Two-faced, I would say...
What?
I would not want to be called that.
It’s way more intense than I was expecting.
Sneaking behind my back
gives small d*ck energy.
Just so you know, tonight,
I’m probably going to kiss her again.
Love Island Games!
Things are gonna start to get
a lot more strategic.
It’s game time!
Love Island Games is always full of
twists and turns.
Are you sh*tting me?
Y’all really brought my ex in?
Who’s thinking more about games
and who’s thinking more about connections?
I’d rather be coupled up with a friend
than a f***ing snake.
What?
Drama!
Boom!
Hard decisions have to be made.
The gloves are definitely off.
It’s time to play!
This is what you’ve been waiting for.
Let’s go!
Bloody hell. What a place!